people are always like hey start a
podcast with Brian it'll be the number
one podcast you got to [__] start it
it's so funny I'd watch that instead of
this and that and dude first of
all not necessarily second of all
dealing with Brian it's so hard dude
because you you're like yeah 3:00 and
then at 3:45 he's like I'm almost there
and you're like oh I'm just not I don't
you know maybe I'll do it maybe in the
future we'll do a a podcast but trying
to Wrangle him is just it's just he's
got his head up his whole [__] so I
was in Phoenix and Brian cin was in
Phoenix just by happen stance isn't that
crazy dude sometimes the Lord works in
mysterious ways I was in Phoenix and he
was in Desert Ridge which I you don't
know I don't know what the [__] that is
but he I'm always playing the actual
spot and then he's always playing like
30 miles out of the actual spot so uh
I'm like all right dude Sunday I'm G to
stay and I'm going to crash your show
and he's like oh okay so I came on
Sunday and he was like do a spot before
me because I want to work my hour and I
want you to watch it and I'm like I got
to watch a [__] hour he's like yeah
cuz I want to know what you think and
I'm like I got to [__] pay
attention now I do my spot did well it
was nice sat down watched about 40
minutes of his act and I'm like I'm
gonna go you know sit with Krist I'm
like I'm gonna go backstage I don't want
to you know so I crashed
his I'm sitting backstage an hour and 20
minutes the guy
does I did [__] 20 he did an hour 20
and then another comic did 20 before me
hey audience you're held
hostage hey you're laughing right now
because you don't know what else to do
and by the way his hour is good it's
actually probably the best stuff I've
ever seen him
do but bring me he wanted me to come on
afterwards and [__] around with him
bring me on dude dude I'm back there
playing Royal match bring me on dude
telling story after Story
okay that's fine but then cut out how
you wish you could kill a bear with your
bare hands you know what I'm talking
about dude hey leave that bit out Bring
me on so I went on and we roasted each
other for a while for like eight minutes
I put it on my YouTube channel so it's
on there you can go check it out